fallout4 spar Harbor DLC ain't so far
anymore it's here baby it's the largest
landmass for Bethesda add-on to date
whole new swampy area new enemies
weapons quests for works we're talking
over 20 hours worth of content and if
you're looking to spend all that time
using these new hot weapons and gear
here's a quick starter guy to better
help you decide where to invest your
time when you arrive by ship you'll
notice right off the bat there's some
nasty fog and by nasty I mean it's
filled with rats stocking up on radaway
sand rad resistant armor will help but
the hell with that
you got these slimy things to worry
about enemies like mutant salamanders
called Gulpers and mirelurk lobsters
tend to mosey around and foggy areas so
I recommend sticking close to the swamps
and water been found well you're kind of
screwed wherever you go and that's cool
because for our Harbor brings you and I
quote the best armor in the game the
marine recon fit super hot so far I
found two legendary pieces brooks sells
the helmet at far harbor for dale and
cogs sells the torso at acadia yeah
unfortunately you're dropping about
30,000 caps for those two but mm really
does look good yet something's missing
weapons far harbour brings a bunch of
new weapons to aid you in your quest to
kill once again you can purchase a few
of these legendary variants right off
the boat and if you've managed to unlock
gun mods perk for you can tack on some
sweet mods so what do you say we do a
hot weapon mod comparison and better
understand which ones are worth your
time this guy's into it first up let's
take a look at this legendary fish pull
the fish ketchup
sucks well how about we throw on a
puncturing mod what's up dogs babe I
like it
this radium rifle isn't legendary but it
won't stop us from decking it out the
rifle itself is pretty solid now let's
turn this semi into an auto not too
shabby but I'm not impressed let's move
on to the legendary lever-action rifle
aka the old reliable it's rocking an
extra projectile the combat it's
slightly slow rate of fire
it's decent from the get-go but let's
add some range to it advanced receiver a
medium scope and a marksman stock ought
to do the trick
damn let's be poppin its reliable
alright but let's get to the grand
finale
the Admirals friend the legendary perk
on this beast does double damage when a
target is at full health good because
it's reload is an absolute chore yet god
damn does a pack a punch ok but let's go
further and mob this thing 100%
nice nose Pinocchio gonna need that
schnoz back though oh you didn't mention
he had friends
damn I like that harpoon okay
last one here legendary meat legendary
great nice camera work that way - really
yes yes sick well there you have it if
you're heading to far harbour this is
what you need thanks for watching
you